what should I do on my first line I
can't let expend they hit counters okay
so when I expand no okay so let's let's
keep this a good right now you talk the
reason why the reason why I'm going to
expand is because right if I AB in to
drink something I'll give you negative
if I integrate something like this this
is the one I well I think it was a tube
anyway fine here it's okay this is no
problem when I'm doing your first chain
rule right because what I need to do to
compensate for this is to multiply
divide by a series of concerts and there
okay
constants are all good right however if
I then ask you to do this right we're
kind of in a little bit more trouble
because you can't just like to klunkins
see here what's the derivative of the
inside function it's gonna be 6x squared
that you cannot multiply or divide by
variables because that's changing what's
going on it's like you know this all is
built upon limits and it's like taking
things in and out of the limits that the
limit is kind of dependent on right so
this is a bit of a problem
you'd have to expand this and you have
to expand it now in exactly the same way
here I could deal with it as is it do
reverse chain rule if I had say for this
guy I had the derivative of the inside
function but I do not write I have no
choice but to expand however in this
case as you'll see I'm gonna get sine
squared plus 2 cos sine plus cos squared
is that okay that's the perfect square I
can expand this to what's this this is
minus 2 sine X cos x
and upon noticing this
I've got cancel cancel and what else is
happening in there I've got the pipe
Accord and Internet so I have the
integral all 1 with respect to X which
of course is okay now yeah
here I'm going in the reverse direction
so rather than taking advantage of like
expanding things out I need to find me
explain things I did just say hey what's
the other knee that will compress this
into an easier for cos squared minus
sine squared that's cos 2x right we did
this one just now in fact
right so if you take this which is in a
disgusting form and put it into this
which is an easy for you can take okay
great I'm going to take advantage of
reverse chain rule and I'm now you get
to this guy okay and you think but wait
what do I do with this okay huh you
don't have it seems you don't have the
pieces that you need in order to reform
this okay now the clue is actually in
the line before that's kind of why I
asked you to do that question even
though it's relatively for you okay
question X is a funny identity posterior
X because what it lands you want is this
however you and I know that because of
the Pythagorean identity here which
turns this into this right side squares
enclosed Squared's I can exchange
they're not the same they're not
identical obviously but I can exchange
them by using that identity namely since
sine squared plus cos squared is equal
to 1 therefore if I want to get rid of a
sine squared or get rid of a cos squared
the way that I would doing is take one
over the other side like say this like
that and that allows me to switch it up
and use a different identity so in fact
there are three forms and I remember
this when we first did the double angle
and indeed there are three forms of this
expansion okay the first one is the one
that you just use there and this is
standard one but then from this you get
to other ones based on do you what sine
Squared's or do you want cos squared
okay now in this case I want cos squares
but let's just rehearse both of them for
the sake of it yeah if I wanted to
change everything into side Squared's
I would get rid of this by using this do
you see that so this is going to become
this is going to become 1 minus sine
squared and I've got another minus sine
squared so it's going to be 1 minus sine
squared so that's fine if in case I want
to do the other thing which is what I
want here I'm going to get rid of this
guy right that would mean sine squared
is 1 minus cos squared so if I sum at
this guy it because squared take away 1
plus cos square cuz there's a double
negative happening there right so since
it's plus I'm gonna give two of them -
one that make sense
ok now I'm still not there I don't have
this there so what am I gonna have to do
to turn that so I've got some choices
I've got some choices
I can either rearrange here or I can
rearrange there okay
I think just for this example I'm going
to rearrange here so you can see and I
don't have the integration happening so
if I've got now maybe you want to write
this with me okay this is my new
starting point the two costs meant X
minus y equals cos two next essentially
what I want is cos squared X as a
function of cos 2x right now I have it
in reverse
okay so all I need to do let's change
the subject that's the fun I'm going to
add one to both sides and then I'm going
to but you okay there you go
so having written that I'm going to take
advantage of that identity here to
integrate this okay so this is going to
be the integral of
this I can take that hop out I guess
it's not really and now I proceed just
as I did before I've done the same
intagram like three times today right
I've got the half at the front what does
the coaster xnt - yeah 1/2 sine 2x 2x
and then what does the water energy also
done this integral just now huh all
right
that plus it okay I can simplify a
little bit here with the fractions there
it doesn't matter I suppose do this but
that's that you've got that in corner
all the real action has happened on the
other does that make sense
now what I encourage you to do when you
encounter questions like this and you
want to calculate all the crime I could
have just an easily asked you to do this
right in fact that might be worth doing
just they ought to see if you worked out
how that process work
I tended to write this like as a student
I tended to write this because I never
screwed that up
write these two I sometimes got them in
reverse order I always got this wrong if
I tried to memorize them and there's
more things to memorize so I tended to
write this and then do whichever one I
needed to based on the question if your
memory is more awesome than one then
feel free to go ahead and memorize this
and go from there you'll be faster but
if you memorize it wrong you are in some
trouble okay